hi herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir sprechen hier heute über die
aktuelle Lage im ukrainekrieg und über
den NATO-Gipfel in Vilnius der morgen
und übermorgen in der Hauptstadt
Litauens stattfinden wird und von dem
ziemlich viel erwarten wird die
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine schreitet ja
aktuell nur langsam voran langsamer als
erwartet und
wir wollen heute darauf gucken was
erwartet die Ukraine von diesem Gipfel
erwartet Sie eine klare
Sicherheitsgarantie erwartet Sie eine
klare Beitrittsperspektive und wir
wollen die Frage diskutieren oder das
Statement so will Kiew Putins von
brechen überall da sprechen wir mit Juri
sagt er ist Berater des ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministeriums der uns live
aus Kiew zugeschaltet ist und wir
sprechen mit ZDF NATO Korrespondent
Florian neuhahn live in Vilnius
ursprünglich hatten wir diesen Stream
mal mit mikailo podolk geplant das ist
ein selenski Berater der musste aber
leider kurzfristig wegen einer
Zielsetzung absagen und wie immer will
ich nicht nur mit den Menschen
diskutieren die mir LIVE zugeschaltet
sind sondern auch mit euch wenn ihr eine
Frage zum Thema habt oder einfach mal
eure Meinung loswerden wollt dann
schreibt uns gerne entweder hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an ZDF heute-
live at zdf.de bevor wir auf den
NATO-Gipfel gucken verschaffen wir uns
aber erstmal einen Überblick wie es
aktuell an der Front aussieht und das
hat Thomas Gonsior für uns
zusammengefasst
ulrikef Süd Ukraine hier warteten die
schwächsten auf Hilfe doch Russland
schickte den Tod die Zivilisten so sagt
Kiew hatten in dem Wohnviertel Schlange
gestanden dort wo essen und sanitäre
Güter ausgegeben werden dann schlug eine
gelenkte Rakete ein drei Frauen und ein
Mann alle zwischen 43 und 47 Jahren
wurden getötet
ausgerechnet Ulrike wo das ukrainische
Militär nach eigenen Angaben noch
vergangene Woche militärische
Fortschritte verzeichnete ebenso wie in
bachmut doch auch der Präsident gestern
im US-Sender ABC ein die gegen Offensive
verläuft allenfalls langsam
wir möchten alle dass es schneller
vorangeht denn jeder weitere Tag
bedeutet weitere Verluste an Ukrainern
aber wir kommen voran wir stecken nicht
fest
das Vorrücken ist dennoch mühsam ein
Grund die russischen Befestigungsanlagen
über Monate angelegt während die Ukraine
auf Ausrüstung aus dem Westen wartete
Minenfelder Panzersperren alles schwer
überwindbare Hindernisse besonders
Kampfflugzeuge würden der Ukraine helfen
russland hat sie nutzt sie meldete
zuletzt militärische Fortschritte in
luman auf die FK und Mainka
in Kumar Region Donezk wartet eine
ukrainische Einheit auf Befehl
Offizier Alexei zeigt in Richtung Front
30 km entfernt liegt sie warum geht's
nicht voran
weil unsere Militärführung Menschen
schützen will sagt er die Russen haben
mehr Leute als wir er geht zurück zu
seinem Fahrzeug und wartet auf seinen
Einsatz an der Kampflinie
ja und über die aktuelle Lage an der
Front aber auch über das NATO
Gipfeltreffen sprechen wir jetzt und
zwar mit Juri sag er ist Berater des
ukrainischen Verteidigungsministeriums
und er ist uns jetzt live aus Kiew
zugeschaltet guten Abend
guten Abend
Herr sag wir haben es gerade in dem
Beitrag gesehen die Offensive läuft
schleppend das sagt auch Präsident
silensky wie schätzen sie denn die
aktuelle Lage ein wie steht es um die
Offensive der Ukraine
wenn man das ganz einfach erklärt so
schreiten wir voran
wir waren uns dessen bewusst
wie stark
wir stark die
Verteidigungslinien von Russen an der
Frontlinien
sind ich möchte daran erinnern dass er
sich um über 900 Kilometer handelt
und diese
Schützengräben und dieser Minenfelder
die die Russen geschaffen haben um diese
Verteidigungslinien zu kreieren ist
präzedenzlos
das gehen alle
Verteidigungsexperten in der Ukraine und
außerhalb der Ukraine deshalb
wir haben unsere
Kräfte involviert und es finden
Kampfhandlungen statt bei der Stadt
bachmut
unsere
Streitkräfte nehmen russische
Aggressoren ein und wir hoffen dass wenn
diese Dynamik aufrecht erhalten wir zur
Werte statt bachmut
demnächst auch eingekesselt
das bezieht sich auch
auf die anderen
frontrichtungen der Feind versucht eine
Gegenoffensive durchzuführen vor allem
was limansk oder piansk angeht
aber heute jeden Tag können wir diese
Angriffe zurückschlagen
und wir vernichten den Okkupanten jeden
Tag und die Verluste auf der russischen
Seite sind viel höher als die Verluste
auf der ukrainischen Seite
sie sprechen ja gerade von den
russischen Verteidigungslinien über
Drachenzähne diese großen
verteidigungswelle über die haben wir
hier bei ZDF heute live auch schon
berichtet jetzt gibt es ja aber auch
russische Vorstöße mit was für einer
Strategie tritt man den den aktuell
entgegen es wird ja von Militärexperten
immer wieder gesagt die haben dazu
gelernt die sein jetzt kleiner und Agila
und deswegen auch schwerer es sei
schwerer auf die zu reagieren
das ist ein sehr dynamischer Krieg
und der Feind
lernt dazu wir passen uns auch an
es geht um eine Presse um einen
präzedenzlosen Einsatz von Atelier auf
beiden Seiten wir sind
etwas
enttäuscht dass der Feind den Luftraum
dominiert wir haben unsere Alliierten
darum gebeten dass wir Flugzeuge von der
zweiten Generation zur Verfügung
gestellt bekommen das wurde uns nicht
ermöglicht und dieses Eiling wird viel
langsamer erörtert als wir uns gehofft
haben der Vorteil im Luftraum ist ein
sehr wichtiges Faktor
Schritt für Schritt
passen wir uns an wir kennen die
Taktiken die Ansätze die der Feind
anwendet
und
wir wissen auch dass das Leben unserer
Soldaten von Vorrang ist im Unterschied
zu russischen Terroristen nutzen wir
unsere Soldaten nie als
Kanonenfutter
wir planen militärische Operationen so
dass wir unsere Soldaten möglichst
aufrecht erhalten
sie haben gerade die Lieferung von
Kampfflugzeugen der westlichen Nationen
angesprochen und dazu habe ich auch eine
Frage aus der Community an sie ist fragt
jemand auf Youtube besitzt die Ukraine
aktuell überhaupt noch so etwas wie eine
Luftwaffe also Flugzeuge
Kampfhubschrauber um solch eine Mission
durchführen zu können
natürlich
verfügen wir über eigene Flugzeuge über
eigene Kampfhubschrauber
unsere Alliierten haben vor eine Weile
[Musik]
bestimmtte
sowjetische modernisierte
29 zur Verfügung gestellt wir haben von
anderen Ländern auch
Kampfhubschrauber zur Verfügung gestellt
soll mit
haben wir bestimmte Flugzeuge unsere
Piloten sind sehr aktiv und setzen sie
ein
es geht jetzt nicht darum was wir
bereits zur Verfügung haben sondern
darum was wir noch bräuchten um die
Parität zu haben die Russen verfügen
über wesentlich mehr Kampfflugzeuge und
deren Kampfflugzeuge sind viel moderner
verfügen auch über Radare die es in
ermöglicht ermöglichen unsere Positionen
auch besser wahrzunehmen das schwer das
den ganzen Kampf für uns man muss sich
auch dessen Bewusstsein
russianes Novak das folgendes Vorfeld
vorgestern haben die Russen
haben gestern wieder die sogenannten
kleiding bombs benutzt sie nutzen eigene
Kampfflugzeuge ohne den ukrainischen
Flugraum zu betreten
so eine Kleidung Bombe ist auf eine
Schule in der Ukraine
runtergeworfen worden vier Zivilisten
sind einfach ums Leben gekommen während
sie diese humanitäre Hilfe in
empfangnamen über 12 Personen sind
verletzt das sind unsere täglichen
Nachrichten
solange wir keine Mittel bekommen um den
ukrainischen Flugraum zu schützen werden
wir solche tragischen Vorfälle Tag für
Tag erleben
geschweige denn davon dass Russland auch
weiterhin Raketen auf die Ukraine
abschießt dass sie auch weiterhin nachts
Drohnen einsetzt gestern wurde wieder
Nicola live mit ballistischen Raketen
beschossen
der Feind mit dem wir zu tun haben ist
ja stark
der Feind ist
bewaffnet aber es ist wie in dem Kampf
von David und Goliath wir sind kleine
aber wir sind schlauer und wir haben
sehr starke alliiert Alliierten die auch
dich Herausforderung verstehen mit denen
wir konfrontiert sind
das Gipfeltreffen in Vilnius das morgen
beginnt ist sehr wichtig für uns in
diesem Zusammenhang
jetzt fordert ja der ukrainische
Präsident selenski und auch sie sie
beide fordern den
NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine der ist aber
aktuell jetzt nicht abzusehen was
passiert bis dahin ihrer Meinung nach
wir haben bereits mehrmals
in den letzten
500 zwei Tagen gesehen
das was wir so wir unsere Alliierten für
unmöglich gehalten haben dass dies doch
möglich wird
wir haben das mit System Heimat gesehen
mit am Beispiel von Panzern gesehen am
Beispiel von F 16 gesehen es gibt
bereits eine politische Entscheidung
dass diese
Vernichtungswaffen der Ukraine zur
Verfügung gestellt werden
auch wenn jemand im Februar 22
gesagt hat dass es unmöglich ist dass
Kief sich verteilt verteidigt das ist
unmöglich ist dass die russische Armee
die Ukraine innerhalb von sieben Tagen
nicht einnimmt das ist unmöglich ist so
haben wir gesehen
dass dies was man für unmöglich gehalten
hat dass dies doch möglich ist wenn der
Wille da ist
wir hoffen sehr darauf dass unsere
Alliierten und das sagen die auch direkt
dass die Sicherheit der ukrainischen der
europäischen Region davon abhängt ob die
Ukraine der NATO ich hören wird heute
sehen wir de facto ein NATO Mitglied wir
verteidigen die Ostgrenze der NATO wir
setzen die NATO war von ein wir
haben dieselben Werte und wir verändern
unsere Streitkräfte gemäß NATO Standards
das heißt wir erwarten auf ein sehr
klares Signal Morgen und wir verstehen
natürlich dass während der Krieg
stattfindet dass die Ukraine nicht
das die Ukraine Türkei im NATO-Mitglied
werden kann aber morgen warten wir auf
ein klares Signal dass der ukrainische
natemitgliedschaft
unvermeidbar ist und dass die Ukraine
unbedingt zum nationaltiert wird nachdem
dieser Krieg zu Ende ist wir haben
gesehen wie viele sehr schnell zu einem
NATO Mitglied geworden ist
Mechanismen die es erlauben
Länder im
schnelleren Verfahren in die Natur
aufzunehmen das gibt es und hoffentlich
wird Schweden auch bald zu einem NATO
Mitglied dieser Mechanismen verstehen
man ist sich der Risiken bewusst man ist
sich der Rolle der Ukraine bewusst und
wir hoffen sehr darauf dass die Ukraine
eingeladen wird der NATO beizutreten
ja das also zu den Erwartungen für den
morgigen Tag ich würde gerne mit Ihnen
noch mal auf einen Teil der westlichen
Waffenlieferungen kommen und zwar zum
Thema Streumunition das ist ja ein
Mittel was international von vielen
geächtet wird der Einsatz war umstritten
wie planen Sie denn den Einsatz von
dieser Streumunition die aus den USA
kommen wird
vielen Dank für diese Frage natürlich
ist es eine sehr wichtige Frage ich
möchte folgendes sagen
erstens setzt Russland das Aggressor
Land diese Streumunition gegen
ukrainische Zivilisten gegen ukrainische
Städte seit dem ersten Tag dieses
Angriffskrieges ein
zweitens wir haben unseren Partnern
unter anderem den USA
schriftliche Erklärungen abgegeben dass
wir die Streumunition nur auf dem
ukrainischen Boden
einsetzen werden und zwar auf den
besetzten
ukrainischen Gebieten nur um die Armee
des Feindes zu bewältigen wir haben
Erklärungen abgegeben dass wir die
strömunition nicht nutzen werden wo
Städte liegen wo Zivilisten angesiedelt
sind wir haben auch
vergewissert
dass wir sehr genau festhalten werden
wie wir diese stromunition nutzen wir
werden genaue geografische Angaben
festhalten wo diese strömmunition auch
angewendet wird nach unserem Sieg werden
diese Region von Priorität sein von wir
die Minen auch entschärfen werden sie
müssen verstehen
das
Quadratkilometer wie
174.000 Quadratkilometer wie viermal
Ungarn mit Minen bedeckt sind wir haben
unseren Partnern
erklärt dass wir wenn wir die Minen
entschärfen werden dass wir vor allem
mit den Regionen Arbeiten werden wo
diese strömen Munition eingesetzt wird
wir verstehen Bedenken unsere Partner
und unsere Alliierten aber wir man muss
uns unseren Bedarf verstehen wir haben
Fell der von 7 km wo wir durch müssen
und diese strömunition
würde uns sehr helfen
das würde uns helfen die kurzzeitig
besetzten Gebiete schneller
frei zu bekommen und dann können wir
endlich die Ruhe und den Frieden auf dem
europäischen Kontinent schaffen
ja also ich höre raus die Hoffnung auf
weitere Waffenlieferungen gleichzeitig
große Hoffnung für den morgigen Tag und
den NATO-Gipfel ich habe zum Abschluss
noch eine Frage aus der Community und
zwar fragt ein YouTube User wie sehr ist
die Situation und Front festgefahren und
welche Lösungsansätze stehen im Raum
läuft das Ganze nicht aktuell auf ein
Party hinaus
ich möchte folgende sagen
und ich möchte dabei goldener zitieren
eine der Gründerin des israelischen
Staates als Beispiel Anführerin sie hat
sie wurde gefragt was das Geheimnis des
israelischen Erfolgs ist das sind die
fehlenden Alternativen wir haben keine
Alternative das ist dieser Krieg ist der
Völkermord gegen den Ukraine gegen das
ukrainische Volk wir wissen unsere
einzige alternativer ist der ukrainische
Sieg und deshalb kämpft die ganze
ukrainische Gesellschaft von angefangen
mit den Menschen die in schützengrenzen
sind über Menschen die im Hinterland
sich um die Wirtschaft kümmern bis zu
den bis zu allen anderen Menschen alle
setzen bringen sich ein
und tragen zum Sieg bei wir dürfen den
Gedanken an eine partsituation gar nicht
zulassen wir wollen diesen Sieg
erreichen wir werden uns durchbeißen das
ist unser Land das sind das ist unser
Volk das ist unser Krieg für die
Freiheit wir werden diese
wir werden diese
militärischen Verbrecher
diese
Aggressoren bekämpfen schauen Sie wie
wir Kilometer für Kilometer Dorf für
Dorf die Ukraine befreien wir werden
diesen Krieg
wir werden in diesem Krieg den Sieg
bringen wir brauchen nur Ihre
Unterstützung dafür ja klare Worte zum
Abschluss vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
herrstag und alles Gute nach Kiew
vielen dank vielen Dank für diese
Einladung
und wir wollen jetzt noch mal den Blick
von Kiew etwas weiter westlich
ausrichten und zwar nach Vilnius wo
Dienstag und Mittwoch haben wir schon
gesagt der NATO-Gipfel stattfinden wird
und Vilnius die Hauptstadt Litauens ist
ein ziemlich besonderer Ort für dieses
Treffen denn in diesem Land ist man sich
der Bedrohung durch Russland allein
aufgrund der geografischen Nähe
besonders bewusst über die Erwartungen
an dieses Treffen und die Stimmung im
nato-bündnis aktuell spreche ich jetzt
mit meinem zdf-kollegen und NATO Kurs
von den Florian neu an hallo Florian
hallo
ja wir haben es gerade vernommen von
Herrn sag klare Hoffnung auf eine
Beitrittsperspektive die USA sprechen
sich aktuell dagegen aus auch
Deutschland ist kritisch ich habe dazu
mal einen Ton von Joe Biden mitgebracht
den ich gerne anhören würde
ich glaube nicht dass es Einstimmigkeit
in der NATO gibt in der Frage die
Ukraine jetzt in die nato-familie zu
bringen oder nicht inmitten eines
Krieges also wir müssen der Ukraine
einen rationalen Weg aufzeigen sich für
die NATO zu qualifizieren
die NATO-Mitgliedschaft ist ein Prozess
der einige Zeit in Anspruch nimmt bis
alle Bedingungen erfüllt sind
Demokratisierung und vieles andere
[Musik]
gesprochen dass die USA während dieses
Prozesses und er wird einige Zeit dauern
Sicherheit wie für Israel bereitstellen
Waffen
Kapazitäten sich selbst zu verteidigen
spricht von einem rationalen weg und
einer Sicherheit wie für Israel was
glaubst du denn was ist eine
realistische Zeitperspektive für eine
Beitrittsperspektive und wäre vielleicht
dieser israelische Weg bis dahin eine
Lösung
also relativ klar ist einfach dass die
NATO die Ukraine jetzt nicht aufnehmen
kann einfach weil das Land ja im Krieg
ist und sollte es in die NATO
aufgenommen werden wäre auch die NATO
sofort im Krieg das ist auch
mittlerweile der Ukraine ziemlich klar
insofern es geht jetzt hier darum auf
den Gipfel in Vilnius ob die NATO der
Ukraine eine Einladung ausspricht die
weiter darüber hinausgeht was die NATO
2008 auf ihrem Gipfel in Bukarest
beschlossen hat damals nämlich sagte man
die Ukraine werde irgendwann Mitglied
der NATO jetzt wollen viele vor allem
aus europäische Staaten dass die NATO
hier weitergeht und eine ganz konkrete
Einladung ausspricht dass die Ukraine ja
relativ schnell am besten direkt nach
einem möglichen Waffenstillstand in die
UK in die NATO aufgenommen wird aber da
gibt es eben auch gewichtige Stimmen die
dagegen sind allen voran auch der
US-Präsident wir haben es gerade gehört
der hier im Verbund mit Deutschland sich
dagegen wird eben diesen Automatismus
jetzt zu beschließen das Argument der
beiden ist dass man sagt jetzt kann man
nicht absehen was
Zukunft passiert was bei einem möglichen
Waffenstillstand passiert auch was für
Bedingungen festgehalten werden insofern
wollen eben beide Staaten die USA und
Deutschland diesen Automatismus jetzt
nicht es gibt einen Kompromiss der sich
hier abzeichnet auf dem man sich bereits
geeinigt hat das ist nämlich für die
Ukraine auf den sogenannten membership
Action Plan zu verzichten das ist ein
Plan der üblicherweise vor einem
Beitritt sozusagen vereinbart wird da
sagt man jetzt okay wenn ihr soweit seid
dann wird es da eine Abkürzung geben das
hat man bereits auch bei Schweden und
auch bei Finnland getan wobei Schweden
ja noch nicht aufgenommen ist
vollständig aber das ist eben immerhin
ein Finger zeigt eine Abkürzung die man
der Ukraine jetzt hier anbieten wird
können aber darüber hinaus wird die NATO
sicher nicht gehen
als ich mal ein bisschen geguckt habe
was für Optionen im Raum stehen bin ich
da auch auf den Vorsitzenden des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses des Bundestags
gestoßen nämlich Michael rot der hatte
Ende letzte Woche vorgeschlagen dass man
von Kiew kontrollierte Landesteile
womöglich in die NATO aufnehmen könne
und nur für diese Gebiete der Ukraine
gelte dann die Beistand vielleicht nach
Artikel 5 ist das eine Option die da
diskutiert wird
das ist erstmal eine Einzelmeinung die
sicherlich von einigen Staaten und
Politikern aus dem baltischen Raum aus
den baltischen Staaten auch geteilt
werden würde aber die sicher nicht
Mehrheit oder einstimmigkeitsfähig in
der NATO ist insofern nein darüber wird
nicht diskutiert aber die Frage ist
natürlich schon ganz offen was für
welche Gebiete würde Artikel 5 gelten
und hier kommen wir zu einem durchaus
neuralgischen kritischen Punkt in dieser
ganzen Debatte denn tatsächlich hätte
Putin jetzt ein veterecht was die
Erweiterung der NATO betrifft er kann
diesen Konflikt einfach am Köcheln
halten am Laufen halten und so lange
gewisse Gebiete der Ukraine noch unter
Beschuss sind oder wo es noch einfach
Grenzstreitigkeiten gibt so lange kann
die Ukraine eben nicht aufgenommen
werden und ich denke mal rein
strategisch wird man sich irgendwann
über diese Frage Gedanken machen müssen
denn de facto hätte jetzt eben Putin ein
Vetorecht er könnte diesen Konflikt am
Laufen halten und so lange wäre eben
eine Aufnahme der Ukraine in die NATO
schlechterdings nicht möglich
ich habe gerade eine aktuelle Meldung
reinbekommen die ich gerne mit dir
besprechen würde und zwar sagt
Präsident selenski das der Gipfel in
Vilnius eigentlich bestätigen muss dass
die Ukraine de facto ein
NATO Mitglied ist das ist ja so ähnlich
wie das was wir auch gerade von Herrn
gehört haben kannst du das schon
einordnen
ja ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen das ist
eine Parallelwelt also die Ukraine ist
nicht Teil der NATO denn dann würde für
sie Artikel 5 die härteste
Sicherheitsgarantie die die Nato hat
eben gelten was aber de facto der Fall
ist ist ja dass die NATO dieses Land
unterstützt wie sie noch kein Land zuvor
unterstützt hat also mit
Waffenlieferungen die wirklich über die
Grenze dessen gehen was vor zwei Jahren
noch vorstellbar war dann gab es eben
diesen Krieg und die NATO ist ja jetzt
mit mit der größten macht den meisten
Waffen da involviert in diesem Krieg
aber eben nicht mit eigenen Truppen und
das ist dann doch der ganz große
Unterschied zwischen dem aktuellen
Zustand und einem Zustand in dem die
Ukraine im NATO Mitglied wäre insofern
ist das ähm auch ein Teil einer
ph-kampagne die die Ukraine hier
sicherlich sehr geschickt fährt aber es
entspricht beides achtens nicht der
Wahrheit
wir haben aus der Community noch mal
eine grundsätzliche Frage für dich und
zwar hat Axel guzzler auf Youtube warum
glaubt die Ukraine dass es jetzt für Sie
wichtig ist eine Zusicherung zum
NATO-Beitritt zu bekommen das ändert
doch eigentlich nichts an der aktuellen
Situation
das ist ein wirklich sehr guter Punkt
das fragen wir uns hier auch ich glaube
es geht vor allem um dieses
psychologisch wichtige Signal dass die
NATO sagt irgendwann nehmen wir euch
wirklich auf dass man eben nicht wieder
vertröstet wird wie seit 2008 das ist
jetzt mittlerweile einige Jahre her dass
die NATO der Ukraine dieses irgendwann
Versprechen gegeben hat und jetzt geht
es eben darum zu sagen wir möchten wir
als Ukraine möchten da einen ganz
konkretes Signale Versprechen haben
wie gesagt ich glaube das hat viel mit
Psychologie zu tun mit einer Motivation
die man der Ukraine mitgibt weniger mit
ganz konkreten Entscheidungen die hier
getroffen werden da ist sicherlich die
Frage der Waffenlieferungen auf der
Lieferung von möglichen F16 Kampfjets
für die nächsten Monate viel viel
entscheidender als die Frage was in
diesem abschlusskommunikation Gipfels
von übermorgen dann eben stehen wird
ja du sprichst es gerade an dieser
Abschlusserklärung ist ja auch ein
Streitpunkt und wenn wir uns jetzt mal
so ein bisschen von dieser zeitlichen
Perspektive für den NATO Beitritt
wegbewegen und mal drauf gucken was
gerade die realistischste und vor allem
zeitlich möglicher Alternative ist
kommen wir immer wieder auf das Wort
Sicherheitsgarantien kannst du uns
einmal sagen was ist das eigentlich was
bedeutet dieser Begriff darüber sind
sich glaube ich auch gar nicht alle NATO
Mitglieder eigentlich oder
in der Tata gehen auch Begriffe
durcheinander da wird von
Sicherheitsgarantien gesprochen jetzt
heißt es noch sicherheitszusagen also
ein etwas abgeschwächte Variante weil
das Wort Garantien doch zu viel
verspricht im Kern heißt es dass die
NATO-Staaten dass einige westliche
Staaten die USA Deutschland Frankreich
Großbritannien sagen wir unterstützen
das Land so wie bisher nämlich mit
Waffen wir rüsten es auf bis unter die
Zähne und wir versprechen dass auch in
Zukunft zu tun mit einem möglicherweise
auch schriftlich festgehaltenen Vertrag
das Ziel dieser Garantien oder besser
gesagt dieser Zusagen ist dass eben die
Ukraine so stark so mächtig ist dass die
Abschreckung groß genug ist dass also
Russland nicht mehr auf die Idee kommen
würde nach einem Krieg das Land noch
einmal anzugreifen das also sollen diese
sicherheitszusagen bewirken aber noch
einmal es sind eben keine Garantien dass
die NATO da selbst mit eigenen Truppen
das Land verteidigen würde es geht eben
hier nur um eine Bewaffnung des Landes
wie es auch die USA für is Rael tun
allerdings eben auch ohne den nuklearen
Schutzschirm den die USA wiederum Israel
angedeihen lassen also hier ist eine
eine durchaus eine Abschwächung zu sehen
auch gegenüber dem sogenannten Israel
Modell
ja wir merken schon ziemlich viel Inhalt
ziemlich viele Verlautbarungen ohne dass
dieser Gipfel wirklich losgegangen ist
ich möchte zum Schluss noch mal so ein
bisschen weg von unserer bisherigen
Zuspitzung der Sendung gehen nämlich
eine andere Person angucken die eine
wichtige Rolle auf diesen Gipfel spielt
und das ist der türkische Präsident
Erdogan der spielt ja sowohl im
ukrainekrieg aber auch in NATO Geflecht
generell schon eine Sonderrolle wieso
hat der heute für Aufsehen gesorgt
ja ein Aufsehen für Aufsehen sorgt mit
einer echten Provokation und zwar vor
seiner Abfahrt vor seiner Abflug aus
Ankara nach Vilnius hat er dort vor der
heimischen Presse plötzlich einen ganzen
neues Fass aufgemacht eine neue
Bedingung eröffnet und zwar für den für
das türkische Jahr zum Beitritt
Schwedens in die Natur das ja immer noch
aussteht also nur zur Erklärung vor
einem Jahr haben alle NATO-Alliierten
Schweden eingeladen der NATO beizutreten
29 von 31 Staaten haben diesen Beitritt
bereits ratifiziert es fehlt noch das
endgültige Jahr der Parlamente aus
Ungarn und aus der Türkei und hier geht
es eben geht es eben vor allem um das
Jahr aus der Türkei und dann hat eben
Erdogan heute morgen gesagt ganz
plötzlich zur Überraschung der
allermeisten das jetzt für ihn eine neue
Bedingung Geld und zwar müsse die
Europäische Union wieder
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der Türkei
eröffnen die seit Jahren auf Eis liegen
und das ist eine Bedingung die hier
wirklich für großes Erstaunen oder eher
Fassungslosigkeit gesorgt hat denn diese
Bedingung kann Europa schlicht nicht
erfüllen erstens weil man einen solchen
Deal Rundweg ablehnt das hat auch der
deutsche Kanzler heute getan ja und
zweitens weil sich die Türkei von
europäischen Werten idealen unter der
Präsidentschaft von Herrn Erdogan ja
wirklich meinenwart entfernt hat wenn
man etwa an den Umgang mit
Oppositionellen denkt oder mit
kritischer Presse denkt insofern ist das
wirklich nicht denkbar und die große
Frage die jetzt auf diesem Gift belastet
ist wie geht man um mit diesem neuen
nein und kann man den Gipfel noch retten
indem man irgendwie Erdogan und seine
Regierung von einem Jahr zum
schwedischen NATO-Beitritt überzeugt
ja wir sehen da sind schon ganz viele
Fragen und Themen offen bevor der Gipfel
überhaupt angefangen hat ich denke wir
werden mit dir auch noch mal dazu
sprechen ich wünsche dir alles Gute nach
vilius schön dass du bei uns warst
vielen Dank
und zum Schluss werfe ich noch mal einen
Blick in die Kommentare und blicke
darauf wie ihr so auf dieses Thema guckt
hier schreibt jemand auf Youtube alles
andere eine NATO alles andere als eine
nato-aufnahme der Ukraine ist eine
Einladung an Russland sich weiter zu
bedienen außerdem zeigt die ukrainische
Armee gerade dass sie eine echte
Bereicherung für die NATO wäre das ist
ja auch ein Punkt den Herrn Herr sagföhn
angebracht hat gleichzeitig lesen wir
aber in euren Kommentar auch immer
wieder dass viele sich Sorgen machen was
würde das mit uns machen mit uns als
NATO äh Land wenn wir auf diese Art
vielleicht in den Krieg hineingezogen
werden würden wir bleiben auf jeden Fall
dran an diesem Thema mit euch gemeinsam
schön dass ihr dabei wart und danke für
eure Fragen bis bald